the u.n bank tribunal has convicted a
member of hezbollah over the
assassination of the former lebanese
prime minister rafiq al-hariri
the killing in 2005 set the stage for
years of confrontation between rival
political forces
judges in the hague have found salim
jamil ayash
guilty of committing terrorist acts and
of homicide
they say ayash bought the explosives and
coordinated surveillance on hariri
beforehand
the three other members of hezbollah
were acquitted because of a lack of
evidence
none were in court today hezbollah
denies involvement
and has refused to hand the men over the
judges say that while hezbollah's
leaders
and the syrian government might have had
motives to kill hariri
there's no direct evidence they did but
they say
the nature of the killing was clear
the attack was an act of terrorism that
was designed to spread fear
among the lebanese population it was
committed for political
and not personal reasons the trial
chamber is of the view that
syria and hezbollah may have had motives
to eliminate mr hariri
and some of his political allies however
there was no evidence that this
hezbollah leadership had any involvement
in mr hariri's murder and there is no
direct
evidence of syrian involvement in it
well rafiquel hariri's son the former
prime minister sartariri says his family
does accept the ruling but wants to see
a punishment being served
we had like many presidents and many
former prime ministers were killed
either in office or outside office and
we never
had any uh truth
of what happened i think today's uh
i mean everybody's expectation was
much higher than what came out but i
believe that the
tribunal came out with a with a result
that is satisfying we accept it
a lawyer representing one of the three
men acquitted says the trial was
ill-conceived
these accusations against hussein hassan
onesie should have never been made
they should have never been approved and
this process should have never taken
place
today we are obviously very happy for mr
onesie but at the same time
i am particularly very saddened that
millions of dollars were spent
on a file so empty and a verdict that
was from the beginning said to be so
mediocre
okay let's go live now to beirut and our
correspondent there zaina
hoda zaina do we think this will do
anything to mend the divisions that are
so obvious
across lebanon now
well hariri's killing and the subsequent
creation of the international tribunal
divided this country
the country the nation is polarized ever
since that
day it depends who you talk to
supporters of hezbollah will call this a
court
a political tool that is being used by
the united states
to diminish the group's influence but
the families of the victims as well as
other lebanese will say that justice has
been served five men were initially
indicted
one of them has since died in mysterious
circumstances
in syria muslim a very well-known
hezbollah commander
and the court finding one man guilty
acquitting
the three others now the international
tribunal its mandate
it has to find an ensure
the guilty verdict without beyond
reasonable doubt
and that is why it wasn't able it
acquitted the three others but
at the end of the day it it linked or
affiliated salim ayash the man
they found guilty with hezbollah and
it's not just that they affiliated
him with mustafa badridin and hezbollah
does not deny its links with these men
in fact
the secretary general hassan nasrallah
calls them our
brothers so at the end of the day this
tribunal does not have the mandate i
think this is very important it doesn't
have the mandate
to try countries or states or
governments or organizations
and this was the agreement when it was
set up in the united
nations but now there is a guilty
verdict will it heal divisions
um it's it's it's unlikely today we are
joined by
um a victim's wife he was the head of
security your husband talal
what do you feel today and and son is
going to speak to us in arabic and i'm
going to do my best to translate
what you're telling
what she's saying is that they waited
for 15 years and
they wanted justice and right now what
what the
tribunal has done is just name
a a few people what was it that you were
expecting
me
[Music]
[Music]
is that this you know so there has been
a lot of criticism
uh directed at this court saying it is
politicized what you saying what you saw
today that it is not politicized because
they acquitted
uh three three people because uh they
didn't have enough
uh evidence against them but what is
your reaction to sadhul khadiri's
statements that that he made following
the verdict
so basically what is saying is that you
wanted them to spell it out
not in not an indirect accusation that
the group was behind
the killing of rafik al-hariri correct
me i mean
so basically this is what a lot of
people have
have told us that indirectly hezbollah
has been
blamed for for the assassination that
the court
um affiliated these men with the group
one way or the other what
people like assange wanted to hear was a
clearer statement on who was
was responsible um for their killing so
some are disappointed they wanted much
more
but right now we have to wait to see the
political fallout
of this verdict xena thank you very much
uh you'll keep us across all the
developments i'm sure in the meantime
we'll talk to you later joining us now
is kevin john heller international law
professor at the university of
copenhagen he joins us on skype from
melbourne in
australia kevin hello welcome to the
newshour how can this be enforced
well it can't really be enforced
obviously there was only one
conviction out of the original five
defendants and if
in the unlikely event that the tribunal
or
the authorities were to ever get their
hands on mr
ayash the convicted defendant he would
be entitled to
a full retrial so basically they would
have to start over
and prove his guilt beyond a reasonable
doubt all over again
so there's a long way to go between this
verdict
and ever seeing mr ayash pay for
you know pay for his sins really why
would he be entitled to a full retrial
given the events today in the hague
it's actually a provision in the statute
of the special tribunal for lebanon that
when you
try a defendant in absentia that if in
fact they are later apprehended they are
entitled to a full retrial and
that's also consistent with
international human rights law so
that's not really a an unclear legal
question at this point
the court of public opinion in lebanon
clearly has
its reaction set in stone to the events
of today
and indeed the events of 15 years ago is
there a chance despite
the chaos for slightly different reasons
given the explosion two weeks ago now
is there a chance that we see some sort
of legal process taking place
inside the country or is that just
completely a non-starter
if only because of the the political
traction that hezbollah
has the way it's managed to weave itself
into the political machinery in the
country
well i think you definitely have to
separate the the legal and the political
there
legally there's certainly no reason why
if in fact mr ayash was ever apprehended
that he couldn't be prosecuted in
lebanon but but as you say
politically it's probably a non-starter
i mean there's a reason why
you know to some extent lebanon was in
favor of an international process to
begin with
precisely because of the difficult
political situation
when you have crimes that are at least
allegedly tied to
hezbollah and and to syria so whether
we're talking about the domestic
legal framework or the international
legal framework and the application
of the law because that's what we've
seen at the hague today you seem to be
saying
this isn't an end to the process this is
just the end
of a chapter in a potential process
which could in theory
unfold in multiple different scenarios
i i think that's a very good way to
characterize it yes
what might happen next
well there will certainly be an appeal
you know this doesn't even end this
chapter of the process uh obviously the
convicted defendant
is entitled to appeal the prosecution
has a right
to appeal there's going to be a whole
another chapter
that is written we don't even really
know how long
that will take the the first stage of
this process took a very very long time
so
the first thing that has to happen is
the appeal run its course
and then they'll have to decide based on
who's convicted who's acquitted
what the next step is an enforcement and
it's very unclear
how you would even begin to try to to
apprehend
mr ayash or any of the other defendants
who perhaps you know
would be uh convicted on appeal it's
there's really no clear path to
accountability in this case and i think
that's been one of the major criticisms
of the tribunal trying the defendants in
absentia
really from the beginning okay we must
leave it there kevin hello many thanks
let's bring in now nadim huri the
executive director of the arab reform
initiative he joins us here on the
newshour
from paris nadim huri what does this do
to lebanese politics
it depends who you ask in many ways the
judgment
um each side of the divide in lebanon
will find some solace in it
some will say look one of the main
suspects was convicted
and that shows that hezbollah is guilty
those defending hezbollah will say well
the other three
were found not guilty of the other four
and
there was no responsibility in a way
lebanon had already absorbed the shock
of these findings many years ago there's
nothing new
factually speaking in the judgment today
and i have to say that with pain because
the process has taken so long
the special tribunal for lebanon is a
bit of a relic
of the past it was really it epitomized
the divisions between the march 8 and
march 14.
these divisions that really dominated
the mid 2000s in lebanon's live
and even early 2000s early 2010s
but today um the real division in
lebanese society
is between those who really want to
change the entire system
and the existing oligarchs in power and
it's very interesting that
actually hezbollah and habiri have been
together in government now many many
times over
and last october when lebanese
protesters were demanding that how they
resign
one of the biggest defenders of havi
were hassan
so politically in a way the stl's
uh relevance to daily political life in
lebanon
has been reduced over the years how does
it play into the scenes of anger that
we're
seeing now day after day on the streets
of lebanon
off the back of the beirut port
explosion blended together with
the political situation as of today
which
in of itself is chaos anyway
it's a very important question and um
there's a very interesting development i
mean the creation of the special
tribunal
for lebanon back in you know 2005-2006
was in a way the lebanese political
class saying we don't want to handle
this issue we don't know how to hold
anyone accountable so please come and
and handle this for us today the mood in
lebanon is very different
for the first time in lebanon's recent
history there's a real popular movement
demanding accountability demanding an
end to impunity
in the country demanding that those
responsible
not just for the murder of having but
the murder of thousands and thousands of
innocents of
other politicians but also of of
everyday bystanders
be held to account now i don't think
they will see in the judgment of the
special tribunal for lebanon
an answer to their demands but i think
that drive for
justice is essential and
in this very bleak uh period for lebanon
for me it's one of the last rays of hope
that for the first time there's a real
movement demanding
accountability rejecting the compromises
of the past
and saying we can do it and i think this
is really the
the moment i think for the lebanese
population to realize
there is no shortcut to justice they're
going to have to build
an independent judiciary they are going
to have the political will
to hold those responsible uh accountable
and i hope that there will be a demand
for hezbollah to give any information
they have
on ayash the convicted suspect but as
the country moves forward
to a point of having one hopes clearly
free
and fair elections the thing about
lebanon
surely is this politicians they're here
today gone tomorrow they come and go
but the system of quotes corruption in
lebanon
seems to represent primacy to everyone
that literally buys into the political
system
or works their way into high political
office so people can't get elected into
high political office without buying in
to the system
that is endemic
you're right and i think the you know
and many people in lebanon have come to
the realization
that this is a system that you cannot
reform and that you actually need to
change
completely now will they be able to
that is the big question today and of
course this
this regime because it is a regime in
place uh is not going to
disappear from one day to the next but
you are right that it cannot be reformed
but it has to be uh changed and one of
the characteristics of this system
is its impunity and this is what made
the special tribunal for lebanon in a
way an oddity
because in lebanon unfortunately no one
is ever
held accountable for political crimes be
they big or be they small
just simply there is no accountability
there was there's not a single
political assassination where someone
went to jail for it um
in lebanon and this is the system we
need to change
many people and i have to say i was one
of them i had hoped that back in 2006
that the special tribunal for lebanon
could break that cycle of impunity could
basically get the country
into a different dynamic that didn't
happen and it became very clear early on
that the investigation was not going to
unravel the system
and today i have to say i am quite
disappointed because
the verdict regardless of however you
want to read it
does not answer the fundamental
questions which is
who did it and why and so the narrative
the labias are going to remain divided
by it
and there isn't really a sense of
justice at least for me today and
ultimately it would really be for the
victims and their families to decide
that
and the fault isn't really with the
tribunal as such
but it's really been a failure of the
international investigation
to really break the case and give the
answers that many lebanese wanted
okay we'll have to leave it there nadi
mori there in paris we really appreciate
getting your
thoughts on this still developing story
thank you
thank you